yes actually respect to you know the
president's here today so you can see
I'm showing my my American colors in my
head either that or I'm a New York New
England Patriots fan but I'm not so
anyway so it's just by chance so I'd
like to talk today about securing an
internet of things and hopefully by the
end of this talk it'll be clear why this
is of intense importance to data science
so what's the Internet of Things it's
this basic idea that we're gonna see
computation sensing and communication
integrated not just in our laptops and
our phones but into everyday objects and
places so we're gonna have things like
the nest thermostat smart thermostat
digital picture frames down on the
bottom right this is a shirt that came
out this summer that actually has
embedded sensors and and it's that well
you work out it can measure all these
properties of your body there's a little
computing module down on the waist which
then it can send out the data things
like fitness trackers you know the basis
watch these sol inserts for your shoes
smart refrigerators smart light bulbs
that you can actuate from the internet
this idea that we're gonna see sensing
and actuation integrated into physical
objects and everyday life so that's the
Internet of Things and we all know it's
going to be a complete security disaster
like we all know this I mean people in
writing about this for you know almost
in a half a decade now these are all
some just recent point points in the
same way the web was when it first came
out as security disaster like we see the
5,000 car pileup up ahead on the highway
but yet it doesn't seem like anyone's
doing anything about it so for example
just this summer
HP security group conducted a survey
they took 10 IOT devices just you know
things like TVs and smart picture frames
and looked at their security properties
90% of them had some sort of security
flaw whether it was privacy concerns or
poor passwords
I mean 70% of them didn't have any
encryption right didn't encrypt any of
the data they sent so anyone nearby
if you're say your TV is over Wi-Fi
could observe what who is sending 60% of
had unsecure updates which means that
you could if you were sitting next to
that TV when it was doing a firmware
update you could masquerade and you
could reflash it with whatever program
you wanted so this is the level of
security that we're seeing in these
things and so people are writing all
these articles about how the Internet of
Things you know it's gonna kill you
right they're gonna somebody's going to
hack your your door lock or it's going
to hack your medical device and we all
know this is happening so the security
of things project this is a five-year
project that we're just starting now
part with the help of SDS I and it's a
collaboration of multiple universities
currently is 12 now at 14 because we've
added two more which is great faculty
collaborators and our goal is to rethink
the Internet of Things how their systems
are built how their software is built
how applications are built from the
ground up the goal of securing these
systems to make the Internet of Things
something that we can depend on and can
trust rather than something which is a
persistent security problem and a threat
and so kind of a high level like what's
our goal it's to make a secure IOT
application as easy as a modern web
application today you want to develop an
IOT application it's a lot of effort so
think the web in like 1994 1995 I was at
the Maker Faire last summer and I was
talking with this this man who had a
company who they were building a smart
watering system for your home and to
have a couple soil moisture sensors that
stream someday to the cloud then control
your sprinklers it took 10 engineers two
years to build this application and I
did not have the heart to ask him
whether it was secure rikes I knew it
wasn't and so supreme colors might not
seem like a huge security threat but you
can imagine things like door locks or
actually irrigation in the farm scale
like today you know somebody breaks into
a system and they steal some credit card
numbers like tomorrow they flood a field
or as happened last year in Germany they
caused a blast furnace to meltdown
and so this project there's a bunch of
faculty researchers and we have grants
etc but I think one of the big parts is
this initial this flagship project grant
from STS IO which is helping us take the
first steps towards this project okay so
what's the Internet of Things you heard
of people talking about it all the time
it seems confusing it's everything from
you know smart shirts to smart industry
and I think that that confusion is
warranted because it's today it's a very
much a marketing term and when people
use it they mean four very different
classes of systems that are very
different security and systems
challenges and very different
architectures and very different
problems and so when they use that term
that could mean any one or more of these
and so it seems very vague so example
people talk about the Internet of Things
as industrial automation that I'm going
to instrument you know all aspects of my
petroleum processing plant a very fine
grain and stream this data out to
maximize plant efficiency or I'm going
to instrument my automobile
manufacturing floor to do predictive
maintenance now these kinds of systems
they're in a controlled environment you
know the people running the refinery can
say look nobody is allowed to operate on
this frequency band except for our
sensor devices and our actuators or Ford
can say look no Wi-Fi devices you know
allowed on the floor they can control
kind of what that environment is like in
terms of the networking but they really
care about high reliability control
systems so these are very tightly
engineered controlled systems in
contrast we've homered with different
class of networks is home area network
so these are sort of similar and that
you want to be sensing things about your
home and maybe turning on lights etc but
these are consumer grade devices this
isn't a house you can't control what
people bring in their house you have you
know hundreds of them maybe in your home
these things have to be much cheaper so
you only use unlicensed spectrum that
raises all kinds of issues how do you
make it work when somebody puts their
their Wi-Fi device right next to it
which is blasts out the spectrum but
these are stationary devices sensing and
interacting with an environment the next
class are personally our networks these
ones
fitness trackers all these things that
we wear that connect often to a mobile
phone and Gateway to get broader
internet access so these are things
which are stationary in terms the
network like I have a single phone I'm
walking with and these things interact
with it but then they're moving through
a physical space so depending on where I
am my phone might or might not have
connectivity I might be interacting with
devices around me or my personal area
rather than the home area and there's
just a couple per person here right you
can imagine these are things that you
have a long-lasting relationship with me
finally you have network devices so
these are things which look like IOT you
know a neat embedded devices but are
basically Linux pcs like a nest
thermostat that's a Linux PC running
behind that neat interface and so they
raise all of the standard security
challenges that Linux razors or anything
of that degree of complexity you know
the number of lines of code running on
your up bracelet is several orders of
magnitude smaller than what's running on
the nest thermostat so those are
actually the Internet's of things and
some people use this term you know
depending on who they are they mean some
subset of these and that's why it can
sort of be confusing as to what are the
problems and what are the challenges but
I think one interesting thing that comes
out from all of these architectures and
there's something which actually a grad
student last year sort of starts
surveying the space and have this great
insight is that all of them despite
their very different requirements
they're very different environments at
very different scales all of them share
a similar architecture that looks like
this
which started calling the mgc
architecture server Joe Kahn MVC Model
View controller so the M or the embedded
devices these are these often small but
sometimes not you know you're a
frigerator but these are the actual IOT
things then we have gateways and
gateways are some you know thing that's
plugged into the wall from Cisco or your
phone these gateways can talk to the
embedded devices using some low-power
you know home area network personally
our network protocol and there would
provide access to the broader Internet
so for example phones we're going to
talk a Bluetooth Low Energy to your
Fitbit but then use LTE or other 4G
technology
or 3G to talk to the club and then you
have the cloud so things running on
servers you know applications big data
stores analytics etc and so you see that
these applications final they all have
this architecture as our embedded
devices our gateway devices and our
cloud devices and so one of the reasons
why building these systems is so hard
and why I think their security is today
such a mess is if you look at how the
code what you write these systems on the
left and you're basically writing them
in see some low-level systems language
you want it to be you know very resource
efficient very you know very small so
you write custom embedded software in C
then when you write the Gateway code
you're writing your gateway code in an
iOS so like in Swift are an objective-c
or you're doing Androids you're using
Java so you're writing then the code on
the Gateway in a completely different
language on a completely different
processor architecture and then when you
get to the cloud the same is true you're
writing something in rails or PHP or
Django or notes you're suddenly now
writing your code in Ruby for rails or
JavaScript for node or PHP or Python for
Django and so what this means is that we
have not only three different classes of
devices running three different
processor architectures right whether
it's like an at microcontroller than ARM
processor than an x86 processor with
three different languages three
different operating systems I mean
writing applications is hard writing
these kinds of complex distribute
applications is even harder not to
mention all of the networking protocols
that are in there that somehow you have
to deal with the hallways this is
amazingly complex distributed systems
and you know it's no surprise that
security is such a nightmare you have 10
to the 6 difference in resources like
the things on the the mem betted devices
have kilobytes of RAM the cloud servers
have gigabytes of RAM and while just
developing these applications is hard
I mean securing them is nearly you know
most impossible just think of the size
of the attack surface if I can
compromise any one of those parts I've
compromised your application and that's
you know in different languages
different operating systems it's it's a
total total mess furthermore today you
know our threats for web compromised all
right people stole ok they still
personal information that's that's
valuable like my social security number
identity theft or you know they stole
credit card numbers ok there's fraud
that's a problem but think going forward
this is going to be very very personal
data about where you are on your minute
by minute basis or what you're doing
this is you know can be not initially
possibly medical but also even sort of
pseudo medical in a sense of fitness
data so this is going to be data very
very personal to us which suddenly have
compromised people be able to get it so
today gosh server was compromised and
then they stole my credit card number
and then the courier company you know
gives me a call tomorrow server you know
the server is compromised and now
organized crime is selling what I'm
going on vacation so people can break
into my house and the challenge here is
that right now there is such a push for
these applications that you're reading
all of these news stories about the
inner of things that's taking off it's
gonna change the world's the next
technology revolution and that means
everybody's rushing to capitalize on
this opportunity you know I think Chris
Rea commented to me that he read some
stat that 45% of developers now are
developing or sort of you know just hard
developers are developing IOT
applications so there's this rush to
develop what's seen as this next new
frontier of the Internet and you know if
you have a hard problem and people are
rushing to solve it they won't and so
the it is like oh let's just avoid this
problem let's not worry about security
let's just deal with it later this what
happened with the web and we've seen the
implications of that so the goal of the
security of things project is really two
goals the first is data security which
I'm going to spend most my time on today
which is to research and define new
cryptographic mechanisms that will allow
us to do secure data
lytx on the streams of data we expect
from the Internet of Things so let me
explain what I mean by this so
fundamentally means security is about
limiting what you can do if we can do
anything then the system can just be
cracked easily and so the question I
want to ask is what do I owe T
applications need to do and if we
constrain them to do just that
then in theory there'll be more security
won't be able to work outside the box of
what's possible if you look many of
these simple one of these applications
are seemingly somewhat straightforward
right with the exception of the third
bullet is you generate some data samples
you process or filter them because you
don't want to send tons of data you know
powers is valuable you don't want to
sort of limit the communication seed on
the edge devices you get them up into
the cloud somehow you do some analytics
like we'd like to for example based on
the fact that you walk to this
particular hike and you really liked it
maybe give you some recommendations to
other hikes you might like combine
things like you know your rating of that
hiker your enjoyment the speed that you
took it what your heart rate was whether
it was a good workout within a GPS trace
of it and from that sort of like the the
Amazon recommendations for the fitness
for the fitness minded and then we're
going to produce some results for an
application review so I'll tell you like
hey you like walking you know on Mount
Tam maybe you should go try this hike on
Mount Diablo and so our goal here is
tough something called end-to-end
security the idea is that the embedded
devices like my fitness tracker my phone
etc are going to generate encrypted data
it's a data that is confidential and
it's not until the data reaches the end
user applications of the recommendation
of like hey maybe you should try walking
on Mount Diablo it is not until then the
data will be decrypted but yet the cloud
and the gateways are gonna be able to
operate on this data and do the kind of
processing necessary for those
recommendations without knowing what the
data is without knowing what the result
is this idea of computing on encrypted
data so this might seem to some people
you know it's like kind of like
ridiculous and impossible
others might say oh yeah this is totally
possible but I was going to give the
brief background because the idea that
you could do this that you could do
what's called fully homomorphic
encryption you could encrypt something
you can do arbitrary computations on it
it was something that was first proposed
like as an open problem in nineteen at
least seventy-five and then actually a
Stanford graduate student answered the
question in 2009 so Craig Gentry who is
here at Stanford he networks that um he
received just this year a MacArthur
Genius award for his for his result and
so the basic result that Craig
demonstrated is that we can take some
data encrypt it perform arbitrary
computations on it without knowing what
the data is and not knowing what the
result is and so it looks like this so I
have a device and it has two sensor
values let's say ten and seven it
encrypts them so they just become these
black boxes x and y it sends those
values x and y to a server the server
doesn't know that they they are there's
black boxes the server can perform say
multiplication on them and produce the
result X Y it then returns that
encrypted result X Y to the client to
the device the device can decrypt it and
get the answer 70 and so we can have as
this case where the server has encrypted
data as an input and encrypted data as
an output it has no idea what the
results of that computation was but it
can perform that computation centrally
with all of this data so this seems like
a mean amazing amazing result but
there's a catch so with this result we
could say aha we can do any analytics we
won't go to any computations any data
science on these streams of data we want
so that's true it's possible but it's
not practical the overhead of this is
you know more than a million fold in a
sense of to do you know multiply is the
equivalent having to do a million and so
it's not practical to do fully
homomorphic encryption that is arbitrary
computations on data but and this is
where the research lies it's been
demonstrated that you can do
particular computations quickly so I can
design a cryptosystem for example in
which I can practically do linear
regression on encrypted data so I don't
know what the input data is I don't know
what the output of the linear regression
is but I can do the computation in a
practical way and so I think one of the
big questions that we're starting to
tackle is can we compute statistics can
we do also can we do analytics on
secrets so answering questions like
being able to compute what percentile
you are in water use without knowing
even what your water use is or telling
you say what your energy use is compared
to your neighbors without actually
knowing what your energy use is or what
your neighbors are and so there's a
bunch of different mechanisms we can do
to achieve this there's not just home
MORF encryption there's also things
called a distributed computation where I
never reveal my value and nobody ever
really reveals their values but somehow
and some distributed fashion without
having to stick all the data on a server
we can still compute an aggregate result
right so I can know the results without
ever knowing what the intermediate data
is this is an example of I'm playing a
game with my friends what's a weight
loss or you know some other you know
who's saved more water or whatever I
want to do and we can together compute
some results in a very efficient way
without requiring a central server we've
only started to scratch the surface on
what we can do so we could do linear
regression we can do some forms of
machine learning but there's a lot out
there which we can't get to which we
don't have crypto systems for and so one
of the big goals of this project is to
figure out what are the cryptic what are
the computational models that we need
what are the operations we want to
perform on these streams of data and if
there are a couple common operations we
want to perform then we can design
crypto systems for them and we can do
them securely while maintaining privacy
without revealing the data and so
there's this whole open question of
based on what will analytics we want to
do or what kind of data science we want
to do how we're gonna build the crypto
systems for them
yeah you said any computation yes X plus
five yes absolutely
so the point is how morphic encryption
was it's easy to you clear systems where
you can do plus their systems are you
conduced times and this is the first
system where you could do plus end times
and if you have plus some times you can
do any computation saying X encrypted
plus something that's not encrypted well
I wouldn't crypt the five but you don't
have the key
oh you want the server to yes yes yes
there are the ways where you might have
ways to translate that so there are ways
you can set it up such that the server
doesn't have the key but they have a way
to take encrypt something encrypted with
their own heat and turn into something
encrypted with another key and so what I
do is I give you a transfer function
where you can take your value and then
you can encrypt the right thing to a
one-way encryption so you can produce an
encrypted value that doesn't mean that
you can decrypt it right of course this
would raise you in to issues of where
you might want to one challenge that
arises there is a ha if I can know what
the value of five is if I did a trivial
encryption of just a one to one mapping
say then I could just enumerate all of
the values and I could start guessing
your values right so there are obviously
issues there your questions
so the goal here is that we're gonna be
able to perform analytics on encrypted
data you see imagine if you're someone
like nest this would mean that you can
do all kinds of learning on the sensor
data from a home but if the nest servers
are compromised the data is encrypted
right the adversary will get nothing but
we can define these computational models
this would be great we have these
building blocks but we also want them to
be adopted we actually want to have
impact we want this to change or people
build systems and so the second part of
the project is system security
it's the idea is let's build a software
framework that actually implements these
models so it makes them easy to use so
people can build out an IOT application
is easily as they build a web
application today in 1995 I took you
know ten people two years to build a web
application today takes two people three
months we'd like to see that for the
Internet of Things as well and it turns
out that the state of the art in system
security on embedded systems on IOT
systems is pretty dismal so I won't go
into the sort of details exactly what
this is technically getting at but I
think the important point is that last
sentence there like free artists this is
the artist that's running and the nest
protect for example it just makes this
assumption there's no malicious code
right like there's no adversaries here
like will encrypt the earth will we send
over the network but there's just this
whole model that you can't you have
complete control of the system which
going forward is not feasible as we see
any kind of new platform like the phone
right the iPhone and there's App Store
emerges we want to be able to load
applications onto them we're gonna be
able to do so securely and so the
current what we're about today is not
gonna let us do that and so as a first
step towards this one of the things one
of the projects the research projects
within a larger project is a new secure
operating system for IOT devices the
idea is if we're going to make these
systems secure we have to start at
Ground Zero you have to make the edge
devices secure if they're not secure you
know all bets are off
and so a few students is a collaboration
between Stanford and Michigan and UC
Berkeley are building a new
open-source secure operating system for
these embedded devices based on arms
cortex-m family which is what you see
served in every you say I beacon or
Billy tag today also these sorts become
the dominant processor and it uses a
mixture of techniques from all these
different parts of computer science so
we're using a hardware isolation to
protect code in some ways protect you
from maliciousness software languages
say using really in 21st century CS
techniques to make these low-level
systems secure right today most embedded
systems are in C there's a language that
was written 40 years ago we think and we
know that we can do better but
ultimately if it's hard to use security
people will circumvent it convenience
versus security people will always
choose convenience and so one of the key
I think the big challenges for us is
that security has to be easy it can't be
that doing the right thing is hard and
therefore everyone always just does the
wrong thing and so you see this all the
time we see this in the IOT devices that
HP looked at where they just send data
and they clear because you know what
actually setting up an SSL sock it's a
little harder and so uh let's not worry
about it right let's hard pressing needs
let's deal with it later but to make it
easy we have to know what the
development model is like easy for whom
easy for how what is hard what do people
encounter and so what you see in these
IOT devices because there are things
that often are directly interacting the
people you know they're things that are
register recognizing our gestures or the
things that we where they have serve a
degree of physicality and interface
which a lot of traditional computing
systems are used to like laptop and
stuff doesn't and so what we see is as
people develop these systems what they
do is they have this rapid cycle of
prototyping modification and why you
take these systems and quickly evolve
them you see this in efforts in the
d.school the whole you know rapid
prototyping and multiple prototyping
approach and I think one
the big goals of the project is we want
to figure out how can we make this
concept of security accessible and
understandable to end-users people
aren't security experts today what do
you do you hire security expert and they
secure your application when you have
hundreds of thousand developer of the
hundreds of thousands of developers
trying to do that diffuse like to purse
two people for three months that's not
feasible and so we need to do is design
this system so that it's easy to
understand the security implications of
what's going on also easy to maintain
them so people aren't just commenting
out the things that are throwing errors
because there's a security violation
now which happens then anyone has
developed the rails app and tells you oh
you have some security problem you
comment out that line the configuration
file which tells you that this happens
all the time so so one approach we've
been looking at for this is a system
called fabric which is done by grad
student here will McGrath advised by
faculty at Berkeley
Bjorn Hartmann the idea of a fabric is
that you want to make it really easy to
prototype these applications rather than
I have a direct code on the embedded C
on the on the IOT device and then write
gateway code and Java and then write
cloud code and rails what they really do
is just merge all of this together into
one approach where it looks like you're
writing a single program somewhere and
then it's just calling out to the
different parts the suddenly if they can
just secure that one piece of code and
secure the code that isn't change on the
edge devices suddenly security becomes
much easier to understand and reason
about I just care about securing this
one piece and it's interfaces rather
than all these complex pieces and so
will is gonna be actually he already
gave the talk he was just it for it so
I'm sorry he will not be giving a talk
on March second so another approach and
this is one which a postdoc here
Lorena's release is investigating is to
take these IOT applications and write
them as this data processing pipeline so
something very much like you see in web
applications today model-view-controller
with the idea of adding this
to fit transformers the thing that lets
me transform data from one model to
another so for example my edge device is
sampling at ten Hertz and then I use a
transform to turn that into a more
meaningful value than just an
accelerometer reading then from this
activity of what I'm doing say am i
running or am i walking I can then over
time I'll process this to a better
estimate like just because I stopped
running for three seconds doesn't
probably mean I stop running is just a
glitch in the data so you can smooth
things out but the idea is by describing
the application of this high-level
across the entire system and all of its
devices that we can actually start to
make claims about end-to-end security
properties and what computations are
needed and therefore what crypto systems
we need so why now you could say the
Internet of Things people I'm talking
about it for you know for 10 years now
or 15 years depending on whom you count
why should we try and secure it now why
should we care about the data science on
these systems now well I'd argue that
the technology has reached a tipping
point so it was at at this point eight
years ago nine years ago arm came out
with the cortex-m series of processors
and when they did they were not
basically they basically were not usable
for are these low-power embedded IOT
applications they had sleep currents in
the order of 500 micrograms which means
you can't last very long on a small
battery but just in the past two years
or so that 500 microamps has become 500
nano amps which means that you can
really build things that will last
device that will last for years on a
coin cell battery and so we have the
processors that'll let us build these
applications in a way we didn't even
just two years ago second we have the
emergence of a networking technology
that it's gonna actually let these
things reach the internet so for a long
time people were talking about ZigBee
and a tour to the 15.4 but for market
reasons those things didn't take off but
about two years ago Apple introduced
ibeacon and while ibeacon is not
necessarily super important the fact
that this means that now all
smartphones first was the high-end ones
but now all of them have Bluetooth Low
Energy this amazingly low power
efficient protocol for interacting with
devices around you means that we can
build these devices and we can connect
them to the Internet
furthermore driven by the phone market
sensors I mean that their energy
efficiency has increased by orders of
magnitude just driven by the power
constraints of phones and what I think
is especially exciting about this is
that you know when people first started
talking about the Internet of Things and
hardware and software how are we going
to build them you know 15 or so years
ago we started tackling all of these
problems but the technology wasn't there
yet and now the technology is here I
mean the research community has been
waiting we've been waiting for this day
when suddenly the devices we always knew
are going to be there are there and they
are and so we have you know people on
this project who are leaders and how you
prototype devices cryptographic
mechanisms low power Hardware low power
software and now analytics but the thing
we still don't know so we now know we
can build these systems we don't know
what the threats are we don't know what
the attackers are these systems aren't
yet widespread and so we have to explore
that and figure that out so on one hand
the technology has reached a tipping
point we now have this tremendous
opportunity this this day that many of
us have been waiting for the calm has
come bathing is actually Steve once
pointed out the other side of that is
it's not too late that think again this
is think of this again it's like this is
the world wide web in 1994 it's there we
know it's gonna be big we know it's
gonna have a profound impact nobody is
really sure yet and there aren't the big
applications aren't there yet all right
Larry and Sergey hadn't had they hadn't
gone to grad school yet right at that
point and so because the big
applications aren't there because there
aren't entrenched applications and code
bases and approaches this means that if
we make progress if we really change the
state of these systems it really could
change the state of what the Internet of
Things is like in 10 years and so while
it would be great to repeat all of the
mistakes of
web and the security nightmare that it
is be great for publishing lots of
papers if we want to think about
positive impact in the world maybe we
should you should do better than that
and I think today we talk about data
science and there's been I think a whole
bunch of great talks about often
gathering data from the computing domain
like blog posts um or social networks
you see these are this is data about the
physical world and the question is what
does the data science that we're gonna
do on this physical data of embedded
networks so talking which is a couple of
applications give you an ideas like why
this is different and why I personally
think this is super interesting this
first one is something is published on
penises now they're seeing the net
National Academy of Sciences five years
ago and so the this is think remembers
back then 2010 so this is like post h1n1
right there's the h1n1 thing super issue
like gosh are we gonna close schools
quarantine all these questions of the
outbreak because disease was so harmful
especially to the kids and so if you
look at PG me ology is the study of the
spread of diseases and often what
epidemiologists would do to understand
infection vectors and what propagation
might be like is they have graph models
of how people interact how diseases
might spread and these are based on some
simple mathematical models like power
log distributions or surveys like write
down on a piece of paper who are the
people you talked with most today
tremendously noisy data not you know not
actually grounded in quantitative
measurement because it wasn't really
possible to measure so a couple of grad
students working with me teamed up with
some faculty here in epidemiology and
now somebody who's faculty at UPenn say
look if we have tiny wireless devices
that can measure when they're close to
each other let's just give one to every
single student and every single staff
member in school and then what we're do
is we're just gonna measure whom they do
talk to what does that contact graph
look like that's not use a model let's
not use a survey let's just measure it
and what does that look like and so
getting a really precise data set what a
real contact graph looks like in a
school over a day
so we got 94% of the school to report
was 788 people of course this is this
physical data it was totally noisy
there's all this mess and it took us a
couple of months to clean it to actually
make it usable for for some analysis
things like nodes reboot their time
sense of break we had to reconstitute
the graph up so there's a bunch of
computer science work and cleaning the
data and then the result was the actual
results from this observation was you
know a top-tier scientific publication
that really sort of broke ground in
terms of how epidemiology should measure
these things for disease transmission
Marcel was telling me just a couple
weeks ago gosh today like this is the
approach everyone uses like today people
are now building new hardware little
tags that are coin cells because this is
how sort of the future of measurement
and graph and understanding of
propagation is going forward what's
interesting is the security here yes
this is five years ago was okay we have
all these devices we have the graph well
the name of the part things the
participants we're gonna put that in a
safe that was our level does here serve
a higher B level of security we didn't
have any other approaches students you
know staff had no way to look at this
data we had no way where they could
query about themselves or because we had
no mechanisms to do so it had to just be
behind closed doors so another
application where theythey this is
another thing with the same graduate
student this is her dissertation for the
inner of things was sustainability and
so this is the monthly build gates Hall
computer science building would get and
so there's the electricity bill $36,000
so just you know that's so much gates
Hall consumes in a month electricity and
you go to the departmental manager so
where does that go how much of that is
computing how much of that is lights how
much has no idea this is all we know and
so we have no way to reduce you know it
is Lord Kelvin said like they're you
know the only way you can improve
something is once you can measure it and
we've we don't know where that's going
we can't measure where it is we can't
improve it there's beef
throwing darts at a board and so student
did was deployed a 200 device IOT system
throughout gates Hall measuring plug
loads in a wide variety of devices using
some really intelligent sampling
strategies to try actually cover
everything and then using some
statistical approaches of sampling based
on say we observe what kinds of devices
are plugged at the network from a
computing perspective she was able to
compute this graph so this is the energy
consumption of gates Hall over a week
and I promise students do normally show
up on Mondays it just happened to be a
holiday that week that's why the there's
not much of a bump and what you can see
is that the computers and gates consume
56 percent of its energy it's over half
of the buildings energy goes to
computers uh-huh
a lot of that servers in the basement
but you can also see like the LCD
displays follow this diurnal pattern of
people coming in there their screens
turning on you can see the little dip
that is lunch and that increase of the
LCD displays it's about equal is about
half of what the daily increases during
the middle of the day so the LCDs are
about half of what you know if you're
about equal to what the lights are
people come in the offices turn the
lights and the LCDs are about equal to
that and so based on this we could then
start making really clear
recommendations to the department about
how you could save energy so you had a
bunch of policies a bunch of approaches
ended up having some good effects for
example after the study we just saw the
tremendous difference between laptop and
desktop energy performance it's now when
new students come to Stanford you know
the computer store its web page lists
the laptops first because they consume
so much less power than the desktops so
another application and this is one I'm
working on now as part of this flagship
grant and this is with Noah deffenbaugh
and earth sciences as well as few people
in computer science électronique mark
Horowitz ural escovitch Chris Rea and
Dan Bonet and then to students Holly
Chang and James Hong and
ocarinas is today five years ago we're
concerned electricity and gates today
California is in a drought and we know
how much water Stanford uses but again
it's sort of like that energy bill
there's just this one line item we don't
really know where it's going or why and
so we're doing this we're building an
embedded sensing device which we can
install into any water tap into any
faucet or shower and it's powered by the
flow of water there's a little generator
in there because these things don't
require much power and what its gonna do
is it measures the temperature and the
flow rate for that tap and the idea is
that we're gonna actually gather on like
a per spigot basis within sounds like
most of Stearn let's just fells a few
other dorms whereas water spent in the
building and also when is it spent and
how is it spent these devices can't
transmit far should have a data mule
architecture where phones running
applications will then pull data off the
devices and send it up to the cloud and
so the big question here is we're gonna
be able to collect all this data and we
would like is to be able to send
messages to students are there
interventions we can make like hey you
know you actually used a lot of water
today or you left this tap on or perhaps
turning the temperature up in a bathroom
because warmer bathrooms lead to shorter
showers for people people aren't cold um
we want to be able to do these kinds of
pattern detection these kinds of
interventions without necessarily
violating student privacy you'd be kind
of neat if all the data on the server it
generates results and doesn't know what
the results are and sends things to
students doesn't know who such that eat
if the server's compromised we haven't
suddenly told somebody exactly when
every student takes a shower and so
figuring out the exact algorithms to do
this this is what we're doing right now
to to make the system secure and so in
summary the goal of this project is
really about gathering the data this
notion we're going to have these
Internet of Things systems that gather
data for analysis and for analytics and
for data science the low level
technology has reached this tipping
point we know
be able to click these huge streams of
data but the privacy and safety
implications that are tremendous and so
the question is can we just do it
differently if we just turn the crank
and repeat the web we will have all the
same problems and so we want to do is
before that day arrives attack this
problem head-on so looking forward
that's the idea is that in the future
we'd like to be able to do not only
impressive data science that allows us
to improve you know sustainability and
energy use and make good observations
about disease spread and all kinds of
applications that touch the physical
world but do so in a way that doesn't
violate privacy that's secure and easy
to deploy and so in that light
I'd like anyone here is interested in
applications wants to build these kinds
of systems we're a resource for you
we want to work with applications people
who want to develop systems if you have
an idea for an application you'd like to
deploy we're going to collect data from
the physical world then do analysis on
it to reach you know have better science
or deeper understanding we would very
much like to work with you we want to
know what kinds of computations you need
to do we want to be able to make it that
you can do them securely in a way where
things like IRB approval are much much
easier because gosh the data is never
revealed it's always secret and that you
I mean not only does that protect all
the so the measurements you're doing it
also allows you to sleep easier at night
so with that let's take questions
you are involved interpretation of the
water sensors twittered cultures and the
warp engines so we haven't yet in terms
so we haven't yet be the short answer we
were mostly thinking this is very much
like hey we'd love to display something
here at Stanford make a difference I
think that this application would
totally be valuable there
I suspect that sort of depending on your
scale of agriculture like if you're
talking about watering hole fields you
know when those sprinklers are on it's
not like you already have your control
system and so for if it's a already a
controlled irrigation system there's
less of an issue of gathering data but
it would allow you to do things like I
detect when there are leaks right you
can see that there's the flow so oh yeah
that's a great point I mean our goal is
open source everything like sure people
want to use this use the software use
the devices be obviously great yeah
partnering with people doing that would
be would be totally interesting yeah all
kinds of sensors well so at the low
level like any sensor right you can
interact a robust and create like today
I mean writing drivers for every single
sensor chip out there is not a good use
of grad student time so we're doing it
very much on a demand basis all right
like so for example the water sensor
basically has a thermistor to measure
water temperature and this has a Hall
effect sensor to a magnet right so it's
like magnet spins and you see a spike of
voltage in the magnet goes by so you
just count the spikes so two very simple
sensors that I'll let us do this and so
it's very much a step-by-step process
and there are hundreds of thousands of
sensor chips like I can but each one is
not hard to do but you've need such do
the one unfortunately no all right so
there isn't a sense of like the bus oh
this is an SPI bus that's but like yeah
every sensor doesn't something it's not
a little commands yeah totally not
standardized which is why not writing
libraries of it it's a terrible use of
grad student typing so yeah the
questions
are you scared I'm scared the
internet-of-things
you will be unless we you know make some
success do you have any ideas about the
ease of use because that's been my I
mean you mentioned it the intense
frustration with security it's a sec
always in the way it is it is right why
that's just seems like seems ludicrous
so I don't with the exception that I
think so certain things in the internet
where that was built with this model and
everything to talk to everything else
and therefore when it can or everything
breaks I've gotten a bit better about
that I'm just understanding there those
limitations but I think it's also if you
whine back line and user interfaces ten
years ago or not designed by user
interface people they're designed by
engineers and that's not necessarily how
you want things to work there are plenty
of systems today where people are coming
up with you eyes that are so much easier
to use because people who are actually
experts in that are now designing the
UI's for example I have um you know
where those little wireless headset
things it's the one from jawbone right
it's the air I guess and I bought took
it out of the box there's no instruction
booklet I'm totally confused I'm trying
to figure out am i loading up the
instruction booklet on the web whatever
and says like insert into your ear and
turn on science ernst mayr turn it on
and then it starts talking to me it
gives me the instructions like oh this
is really easy so I'm like take your
phone open up the application like oh
you should I'll wait until you open up
this is such a better user like reading
a manual so I think we are gonna get
progress there and a this is actually
why I think Bjorn Hartman who's I mean
desperate typing and gener interface
like it's absolutely critical that he's
part of the project to understand like
what are the cognitive models that
people can think of and can reason about
that are simple and easy but actually
enable them to do useful things so I
mean we need need experts in that
otherwise it won't be any better and we
want it to be better
what about metadata yeah that is a great
point so it turns out for example in
this water application that like oh
we're gonna measure these faucets at
these times
that's not very sensitive data you know
less concerned about that but then the
data of oh this phone was in the
bathroom at this time and it's the one
that data muled this data from that that
metadata the actual turns out the data
we need to collect to monitor the system
to make sure it's working correctly is
far more sort of privacy prying than the
data of the system itself and I think
that is a really interesting and
difficult challenge in the sense of the
data you gather okay we can protect that
but then like when you want to do the
system monitoring like is it working
that stuff turns out to be if a privacy
there it becomes much trickier because I
want to know for example this phone
seems to be taking lots of data off the
devices but never reporting it there's
something wrong with that phone at some
point I need to talk to that person so
now privacy there's a sort of a privacy
battle there of course you might send
them in an ominous message and see if
they get back to us but some wait wait
like we want to debug it is there a bug
in our code we so great correct I mean
that's actually where I mean the data
itself you can protect like the real
challenge I think is going to be in the
metadata and what sort of things we need
to do there great point yeah
setting click at the gate up do you mean
if I use machine learning will I be able
to break the privacy of all right so
differential privacy is a little
different but I mean I think people have
demonstrated the ability to do machine
learning algorithms on encrypted data
so ideas like the algorithm doesn't know
what the data is there's no sense of
what it means through strongly strong
cryptographic statements as to what that
is and there's no idea what the result
is and so at that level like you are
absolutely protected now whether or not
you could figure out something from like
the timing of data I mean those are sort
of meta sort of medic what metadata side
channel things which might be I think an
issue for example even if we sort of
keep all the data on a floor
confidential like about you know water
use etc at some point we're gonna know
something about what happens on a given
floor right there just notion of what
that's the level which want to examine
the data and that's gonna say something
rights like one floor never takes any
showers we've learned something about
that floor even if we haven't learned
something about an individual person
even when you're doing aggregate results
I'm not sure if that answers your
question from your face I think no but
so can maybe if you ask it again I'll
understand it
oh excuse me yeah yeah so uh that is a
point of gosh the server has the truth
and we're now limiting our questions you
can ask but then maybe if you finagle
the questions you can still figure
things out you weren't supposed to know
queries but at this point the server
doesn't know the answer right like only
the client can actually get the answer
so we're not it's not the differential
privacy approach where we're going to
have the server limit what questions you
can ask whether we server can't reveal
something in itself doesn't know but
your absolute isense of when then people
can ask questions and they get answers
to them which they decrypt differential
privacy is absolutely an issue and since
if I can like figure out who was that
was showering at a certain time that
would be really bad yeah so this
encrypted computation thing the key is
stored on the client for each breach
client that is one approach yeah right
what happens if you lose your phone if
you what happens to your data can you
get it can you get it well so get it
back can you get your data back so a
sense of like I've lost my phone which
then moves like key so those are key
yes there are kinds of techniques for
key recovery right in the sense that we
can do all kinds of authentication to
actually get you the key back there's
yeah
so you reflected on love at all
insecurity there are ethics before that
to work with computers I may as you to
time sharing sighs yeah and a strategy
that murders over incrementally is
really trying to create back there
pretty secure barriers whether they were
virtualization over carnal and there was
capability architect the whole bunch of
different struggles is it been a part of
extending our lines like that
distributed systems where you create
kind of capability this who can touch
this data who this data could talk to
you so the answer is yes and I think the
term that they approach that really has
seen tremendous success there and one of
the folks in the project daveandlisa are
the leaders of information flow control
where traditionally computer systems to
really look at like oh well you can do
this but not that like you can open this
file but not that file instead these
sort of imagine it executive or
operational things what you can do what
you can't do instead information flow
control says look let's not care about
any of that so we're gonna say what data
can you write what data can you read
there's you talk about security in terms
of the data and what will happen is in
an information flow control system is
you can for example say look you know
the you can either you know read you can
either write to the network or you can
read the password file but I can enforce
that you never do both if there's no way
that information you basically can set
up a system where information cannot
flow from the password file to the
network and the system just has to
enforce that these even know doesn't
know what a password file is doesn't
know it the Newark is just that there
are simple labels and says well you have
label this and you can't you can't have
these two labels at the same time you
kaboom
I won't you're shut down like you try to
write to the network and I'll just tell
you sorry to that right that's not
allowed to propagate and that is emerged
as a really effective way to protect
data and its flow through a system and
people have done that for distributed
systems absolutely
it's a bit tricky because often it's
this example of it is an amazing
technique that a super clean super
effective and super hard for anyone who
doesn't work in that space to wrap their
head around so one of the big results in
that space was this operating system
called high starch used in every single
level of the operating systems like just
your system like literally this network
password file thing the student wrote
that paper was a student here he's now a
tenured professor at MIT would you read
that paper and Wow it requires several
times to understand exactly what is
happening because it's it's not
something we usually think about once
you get it
oh it's clear right but it wouldn't be
something that's accessible to two
people working for three months so can
we somehow make it you know easy to
understand what's happening that's I
think it open question that David is
really interested and looking at the
start of looking at actually having
access control yeah I think so I think
that's that's very very right but I
think it's also let's just think about
not just the operations but about the
data like you I don't care that you read
like here's what
okay great thank you so much
you